we are in a dark and dangerous place in
America tonight where politics is
driving our system of justice instead of
Lady Justice being blind to politics the
story of Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn is at that intersection of Justice
and politics but in the end is so much
bigger than politics whether you're
left-right agnostic or indifferent at
its core this is a story of injustice it
involves the usual players protagonist
antagonist big players and big players
we pretty much know the who what where
when and how the fundamental question On
January 24 2017 was Michael Flynn
treated as per the rules like any other
FBI target the answer a resounding no he
was treated differently which brings us
to the question why the answer to why
brings us to an unsettling place foreign
to all of us who have spent our careers
revering the American system of justice
it is that system of Justice that
distinguishes us from other countries we
are fair we strive to achieve justice
for all no one is above our law and no
one is beneath it it's why people clamor
to come here legally and illegally as
strong as a statue of Liberty is in the
harbor in New York so also is a symbol
of blind Lady Justice in courtrooms
across this great nation the facts of
this story are simple Flynn was in the
crosshairs of the FBI targeted by the
same players who we already know from
publicized tech messages and emails
tried to prevent a certain candidate
from becoming president and promote
another they were dirty
they were liars some under oath
they were leakers and they were corrupt
now there's one important fact that you
need to remember the conversation Flynn
had with the Russian ambassador during
the transition was legal perfectly legal
take that one to the bank it is what is
done in every new administration the set
up Michael Flynn was called by Deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe and told that
the FBI wanted to talk to Flynn about
the Russians and the quickest way to do
it was to keep the lawyers out a clear
violation of protocol white house rules
and ultimately Flynn's constitutional
rights do we know this because US
District Court Judge Emmett Sullivan
ordered prosecutors to hand over FBI
files of the Flynn enterin interrogation
instead of sentencing him as scheduled
48 hours later the files are handed over
as for the judges directive although
incomplete and redacted they confirm
what director Comey himself admitted and
what the judge apparently suspected that
the DOJ and FBI hatched a plan to
deliberately and intentionally avoid
protocol standard operating procedure in
an effort to entrap Michael Flynn
now Comey even admits this when he pulls
off the mask of Cardinal Comey to reveal
the face of a hardened political
operative who deliberately trapped Flynn
he not only admitted it with unfiltered
hubris he prided himself on what any
other decent man of honor would have
been horrified to admit that the rules
the law and the Constitution matter not
when politics is at stake
we probably wouldn't have done or maybe
gotten away with in a more organized
investigation more organized
administration in the George W Bush
administration for example or the Obama
administration something you wouldn't
have gotten away with in any other
administration so to be clear the FBI
went to great lengths to disavow Flynn
of any concerns telling him no lawyers
need to be there a plan that Comey
McCabe instructs strategized going to
great lengths to keep even the
Department of Justice out and we now
know that there were many arguments
about whether or not they could and
should do this so you may be sitting
there saying hey Flynn was a general he
should have known not to lie you're
right you are right but what is a lie is
it a mistake a miss remembrance a memory
that simply doesn't remember everything
or an untruth and if an untruth does it
require an intent to deceive to be a lie
now Flynn already knew that any
conversation he had with the Russians
was recorded and that the FBI would
certainly have a transcript of his
conversation with the Russian ambassador
so there would be no point in lying even
more compelling agents truck and the
other FBI agent who interview Flynn say
he did not lie quote both had the
impression at the time that Flynn was
not lying and did not think he was lying
they even said he was unguarded and
friendly the notes further described
that Flynn did not give any indication
of deception curious however is the
failure of the FBI and the Special
Counsel
to provide the FBI's 302-a Flynn to
Judge Sullivan so how does the FBI file
a false statement charge when the FBI
thought it was no
I and you're probably asking yourself
why would Flint even plead guilty to
lying when he wasn't lying the answer
Flynn based on his record of 33 years as
a decorated military man is an honorable
man who may have realized when he saw
the transcript that what he said was not
consistent with the transcript or maybe
he pled guilty because he ran out of
money to defend himself even having to
sell his house to survive or maybe to
save his son also in the crosshairs of
these people and for those of you who
think the FBI was just trying to get to
the truth you're wrong if they wanted
information if they wanted the truth
they could have shown Flynn his
transcript of his conversation to
refresh his recollection to get at the
truth but no they didn't want the truth
they wanted to take down a bit player to
get to the big player on Tuesdays the
parties will appear again before Judge
Emmett Sullivan a jurist unafraid of the
swamp a judge who has a track record of
calling out prosecutorial misconduct a
man who does not tolerate injustice or
abuse of power judge Sullivan can throw
out this guilty plea if he concludes the
FBI intentionally interfered with their
target Flynn's
constitutional right to counsel the
story of Michael Flynn continues on
Tuesday